he's Alabama head coach Nick Saban
joining us on the program coach how are
you today doing great Dan how are you
I'm doing okay I learned it was reported
that you learned how to text an email
during the quarantine can you confirm or
deny
well I receive emails not much for
texture
I received text so the big news was as I
now have an email and I receive emails
have you sent an email on your own no I
cannot and then Ted who texts you all
kind of people text me okay I need to
respond I just call it yeah that's what
we used to do I tell my kids that I say
why don't you just call me like you know
not everything has to if I text them
they'll respond if I call them they
don't answer I've been through the same
program how many calls are you getting
about 200 I probably had at least you
know half a dozen teams call about -
probably more than that about some of
the other players but specifically about
- I think you know teams that are
interested in a quarterback are going to
be interested in to a other than that
you know I think the other guys they're
just interested in the other players
that we have in the draft
what are you telling or reinforcing with
these coaches who were interested into
it what - is a great player you know
he's very instinctive he's very active
with the ball he's got a great feel for
the game his great personality you know
really good person great teammate to
have on your team he's a good leader and
I think he's proven that over and over
again I think that you know from an
injury standpoint what I try to tell
teams is every time - has gotten hurt
here it's been extending a play where he
should have never even got hit so I
think the lesson in self-preservation
and he needs to learn as a quarterback
so he doesn't take unnecessarily hits or
is probably you know
what he needs to learn how to do now the
guy's a great competitor so he's always
trying to make a play what you really
don't want to take that away from them
but you also want them to you know know
when there's nothing there and there's
no sense in you know taking a hit that
you don't need to take are you guys the
first quarterback coach combination to
have hip surgery in the same year well I
never never thought of it that way but I
guess you're right
let's get some [ __ ] let me let me
say that are you doing way better say
well no he's hip well I I think it's hit
this fine you know everything that our
doctors say here about the way his rehab
has gone all his rechecked physicals
that we've done internally here healing
process is great and surgery weren't
great the rehab has gone very very well
I have not seen to a workout since you
know we didn't have a pro day here he
personally so I don't know where he is
relative to what percentage he is today
but I think everybody's feeling is he's
going to continue to make progress and
get back to 100% very shortly what is to
do better than Jill burrow well I don't
like to make comparisons and players you
know they're different style players you
know Joe's a bigger guy he's very
athletic you know he can run he played
on a very skilled team with the wide
open offense good decision-maker Joe
extends plays you know I mean but I
don't like to compare players you know
to is a little different style player
but I think both of them are very
effective at what they do I guess the
thing that I that stands out or I've
been told many many times it's the
common theme with two of the ball comes
out of his hands differently than
anybody else that a lot of people have
seen and I know Trent Dilfer went
overboard saying that you know two or
throws the better ball than Dan Marino
or Aaron Rodgers did but there's
something about tua that is magical
Chris Fowler said I first time I saw him
in person and I watched the ball it was
different there's just a different way
he's throwing the football can you
explain what that is
no I did I think he's got great hands I
think he has a very quick release I
think he's very accurate with the ball
and I can't I be on that I can't really
explain it but I do I don't think those
assessments are incorrect there is a
special talent there when it comes to
this guy's ability to throw the ball a
critique have touch on the ball and do
the things that you know guys have to do
to play winning quarterback you know so
you know he is special I you know I
would probably you know just my
experience as a college coach now I
played against all those guys in the NFL
when I was in the NFL but as a college
player Drew Brees when he was at Purdue
and I was at Michigan State you know is
probably the best comparison and I can
make as college players all those guys
that she talked about you know are
little different style guys and you know
they're all very very good players and I
think two is going to be a very very
good player to you go back to the
dolphin days and you talked about this
if somebody and I'm paraphrasing here so
correct me if I'm wrong but if you're
passing on him it's sort of like when
the Dolphins passed on Drew Brees
because he came over from the Chargers
had the injured shoulder here but you go
back to like you're talking about how
great Brees was in college but he's
right there in front of you and then you
guys decided on daunte culpepper but
what what was it about Brees but but it
was the same scenario it wasn't you know
our first choice was it take two agrees
yeah you know it's the medical people
made that decision
you know relative to Drew Brees and
silver in situation it was just throwing
him arm and all that that was a medical
decision it was not an organizational
decision you know we wanted to take to
rebreathe he's the first guy that we
brought in he's the first guy that we
made a deal with right but it was a
medical issue that created that all
right so this may be the same scenario
for whatever team is interested in to
you know it's you know it's going to be
a medical decision I don't think it's
going to be a performance issue yeah and
look
not you know casting blame here I'm just
trying to understand where you were
talking about hey if you pass up on him
it's gonna be like when you know we're
looking at Drew Brees the same way and
of course drew ended up as you know the
old-time leading passer in NFL history
so that that was like and I hope you
understand where that's coming from I
just wanted to understand what you were
saying and comparing that to Toa
yeah well I think it's the same scenario
I mean if you pass him a guy he has a
chance to be one of the great players in
the history of the NFL in my opinion how
much fun you got Judyann drugs who are
gonna go in the first round like when
you have that amount of talent there do
ya do you ever have to keep somebody
happy with either giving them the ball
or throwing them the football I think
that was the unique thing about this
receiver group you know because we have
two more guys that you're going to be
talking about next year in you know
Smitty and Waddell so we had four guys
and the unique thing about this group
was that they were all for each other
you know there was never a selfish
moment that we ever had to deal with
they all made a lot of great plays but
they were never worried about who made
the play and they kind of understood
that how many catch eight balls in this
game but somebody else may catch eight
balls the next game but if we go do what
we're supposed to do we're going to have
the production that we need to showcase
our talents and and they all did that
extremely well I mean and that's really
unusual because a lot of times receivers
you know our guys that can be a little
bit self-indulgent in terms of you know
getting me the ball you know and these
guys were never that way he's Nick Saban
Alabama head coach projected to have six
players taken in the first round this
year when you stumble upon an old
college game that you have coached in
you stop by and watch it an old college
game that I've coached in you know I'm
not much for watching old games where I
know the outcome unless there's a
technical aspect of the game that we're
trying to use to prepare for
next game or another game so I guess I
don't put the past month oh when you're
watching TV you flip through the
channels you haven't stopped on an
Alabama game no no you know I really I
have not I don't what do you watch it
all morning well I spend all morning
watching film preparing for next year's
season I would watch III watched some of
those golf things you know sometimes you
know the greatest rounds ever and you
know maybe some great tournament or
something but when you spend all day on
football and then you go home at night
you want to watch it on TV I mean that's
not I mean I know everybody thinks I'm a
grinder but I don't you know there's a
limit I have a lemon we all do it's like
when I go home the last thing I want to
do is talk sports right talk anything
music you know yeah well even when we
play a game
you know like we'll have all kind of
family come in for a game and we'll play
the game in the afternoon and I get home
at 8 o'clock at night after I do a TV
show and a press conference and talk to
a bunch of recruits and all kinds of
stuff and they'll want to watch whatever
games on at night and I'm like I'm like
when the other one watch do you have a
guilty pleasure now during a you know TV
wise during the coronavirus you know
tearing odd kind of you know we look for
things on you know the amazon netflix
all those things try to find a series
where we can watch you know like one
episode here in one episode there and
something that keeps your interest so um
you know to be honest with your vistas
all much longer or run out of things
watch you you might be watching some
football hold Alabama football games if
that's the you're not doing Tiger King
are you you don't have you seen that non
commander and by the way it's not LSU
related just letting you know when when
you see that I want to make sure you
know that hey it's great to talk to you
I hope you have a good time watching the
draft and we appreciate your time as
always
okay Dan thank you buddy take care
that's right that's Nixon
Alabama head coach